si la localidad de luque y la localidad
de ayudan o francis que el aeropuerto de
esta ciudad han sufrido en las últimas
horas un bombardeo han sido en
bombardeados en esta zona del oeste de
ucrania una zona que en los pasados días
no había sido afectada intensamente por
los bombardeos del ejército ruso y de la
aviación rusa a diferencia de lo que ha
ocurrido en el este en el norte y en el
sur del país y esto ha hecho sonar las
sirenas de nuevo las hemos ido aquí en
donde nos encontramos precisamente en el
oeste de ucrania y todo esto ocurre
cuando el presidente ruso ha comunicado
que está planteándose precisamente esto
desplegar las tropas más tropas en las
fronteras del oeste de rusia algo que
amenaza con internacionalizar aún más a
la crisis bélica actualmente en curso y
que podría incluso afectar directamente
a los países que son miembros de la
unión europea